and we stand with the Palestinians lying
we understand that you're a news channel
you have your part in policy but where's
your
Humanity Islam net is establishing a
Masid and a community center if you
donate to build this Masid Allah will
insh build a house for you in Jenna with
bricks of gold and silver every person
who prays in this Masjid every child
that memorizing the Quran you will in
share in that reward donate now guys and
do not
delay
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshah in this
protest there was a protest that was
done if I'm not mistaken and there was
this Egyptian sister may Allah subhana
wa tala bless and preserve her and you
can see the plight of the people are
ranging from all kind of backgrounds
Muslim and UNM Muslim this is a human
issue this is a humanitarian cause this
is something that anybody who has an
atom weight of mercy and heart we have
seen Israeli settlers these thieves
occupying genocidal individuals laymen
by the way casually look looking and
claiming that they do not care about
what's happened in Gaza they are
basically claim advocating extermination
a outright genocide this is the lay man
I'm not talking about the IDF I'm not
talking about the politicians that's
what they're doing look how this um
Egyptian system may Allah subhana bless
and preserve her and Grant her the
highest ranks of Jenna how she confronts
a CNN reporter who cowardly runs away
after what she had to say watch this for
yourself inshallah lying we understand
that you're a news channel you have your
part in policy
but where is your Humanity
where where is your Humanity how many
children died I ask you to condemn the
Israeli government a this a this you
liar you
liar and we stand with the Palestinians
and we stand with Arabs and they TI and
chames the narrative because you own the
narrative see this is our problem you
own the narrative you own the United you
own Hollywood you own all these
mouthpieces where are our voices our
voice need to be heard as well we've
been watching your channel and instead
of mourning our death instead of
mourning these Palestinian children
we've been having to deal with more
dehumanization of Arabs we ask you to
condemn where are your condemnation
where is your Chanel cover this cover
this say the truth we understand you're
an employee you're just a puppet you're
just about I understand you have your
foreign policy no I've heard you
understand you represent your government
but that being said you're a country
that's claimed free speech and now we
are watching an occupation and we are
watching the result of your silence of
your misrepresentation of she put that
woman in her place because you know why
the narrative is always on their side
because back in the days they had TV we
had TV and we would pick certain
channels that we could choose from just
a specific couple who was owned by we
all know who the Western media who who
are outrightly biased hypocrite
individuals and now the whole situation
has changed and I've said this years ago
now alhamd Allah has given us the power
that myself someone like myself you know
Subhan Allah um can sit at his home put
his camera on on his phone and record
and have a YouTube channel and Muhammad
hijab and Zan and many like us and not
only us you guys at home with your
social media profiles the fact that
you're sharing this information and the
millions and the billions may Allah
subhana tala bless you guys because if
it wasn't for you guys this would never
reach where it's reached today and
Subhan Allah today there is a massive
protest of maybe about a million plus
people who have hit the streets Muslim
non-muslim Jews Christians Hindus seeks
anyone that's a human being has come to
the streets for the plight of the
Palestinian people and this is only
happened why because they have they are
the ones who are controlling the social
media Facebook Instagram and all that
kind of stuff Subhan Allah and guess
what we are using their very platforms
to expose the Zion government and may
Allah subhana bring them an end that
there will be one state which is
Palestine which the Jews the Christians
and the Muslims who have lived for
centuries go back to living like normal
human beings and helping each other and
being neighbors with one another and
this CNN reporter got owned and we are
owning them and we are showing the truth
as you can see when we show the reality
carry on posting do not stop show those
videos carry on my brothers and sisters
inshallah so don't stop carry on Posting
and sharing
those horrific videos but guess what the
world is going to see and Israel is lo
losing and Israel is losing this battle
and guess what the more they carry on
the more the world is going to hate them
for what they are doing to ilent
Palestinians this is going to go down in
history brothers and sisters it is as
Muslims we have lived with the
Christians and the Jews side by side so
much so when Jerusalem was conquered and
the Christians kicked out the Jews it
was the Muslim Muslims the Muslim
armies who brought Jewish families back
into Jerusalem Subhan Allah so our cause
is against Zionist not the Jewish people
let's make that very clear inshallah and
we yes and please please carry on the
campaign do not stop may Allah reward
every single one of you guys and please
just one reminder if you're going to
these protest if you're missing your
Salah you are doing no justice you are
doing Injustice to Allah you are
wronging yourself Allah's Right comes
first before any human beings for that
matter make sure you pray your Salah and
then go to these proes in for the right
intentions that you get rewarded
inshallah till next
time the prophet Ali wasallam said
whoever builds a Masjid for the sake of
Allah subhana tala Allah will build for
him a similar house in jenah on that day
where Allah subhana T tells us that our
books will be given and every little
atom weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masid I never had the money to
build a Masid Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if youve built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra
[Music]
Rewards
l